glad you got some funny video for us  alright so we usually try to leave folks  with a smile but today get ready for a  live NFL safety haha Clinton dicks can  tackle pretty much anything on the field  but a new Instagram video he posted  shows he's not completely fearless watch  what happens when he encounters a bear  and it's cub the six-foot one 211  pounder who played for the Bears last  year he can't make this stuff up scooter  and runs for his life  no one was hurt the Bears were scared I  never liked that scooter anyway  and his name is haha yes he played for  the Bears last season he played for the  Bears last season confronted those Bears  ran away and he's kind of he's kind of  running away in real life from the Bears  not running away running away but he's  now signed with the Dallas Cowboys so  making a change in his driveway also  apparently making a change in real life  alright thank you very much